okay my final guest an actor producer
and director who recently
founded the civic engagement platform a
starting point
oh it doesn't say he's also captain
america i guess people know that chris
evans
all right yes i think you've done that
in a few movies hey how you doing uh are
you in uh
i know you have places in la and you're
i know you bought and guided yeah yeah
boston guys are very loyal to your home
turf
of boston you know i think in this these
these uh
the the carnival of horrors that is 2020
i felt like i just wanted to be
home yeah i i figured you would and i i
read that like
for you quarantining you said it was not
that big a difference because
you're home alone all the time anyway is
that because never leave the house
yeah is that i mean that's not true i'm
not like you know i'm not like
you know i'm not like agoraphobic or
anything but but i i just you know it
takes me a while before i need human
contact i like being alone
maybe it's that or maybe you're kind of
guy who just doesn't need to leave the
house to get laid
maybe it's that i haven't yet i wish
that were the case oh yes
poor you by the way some of the women
around our office have mentioned that if
you need someone to quarantine with
they they are they thought i was chris
hemsworth
they're volunteering yeah anyway let's
go to politics
i know you started this website called a
starting point i'm going to let you
explain it it's your baby i
you were talking to me about this years
ago
yeah you've been brewing this a very
long time i know it's really important
to you so you explain what it is and
what you want to accomplish with it
sure well it grew over time i think when
you and i spoke about it it was only in
its infancy initially it was just meant
to kind of
demystify certain political issues i
wanted to try and
you know i'm a bit of a political junkie
and i know a lot of people are wary of
the political landscape because it's
daunting
and and when i tried to google things in
the past i found that there is
a missing piece there this kind of
gentle entryway into kind of basic
political political understanding
so we wanted to create a site that would
ask the questions that the average
american would want to know you know
what
what uh what's daca what's the
difference of medicare and medicaid you
know and then have it answered by
uh people across the political spectrum
so that's where it began
and then over time it grew into these
other sections now that
try to explore debate uh but but
ultimately creates
uh engagement just just more
participation in the political process
and it's and what i love about it is
that it's well a couple of things one
it's bipartisan
you know i i last year at the end of the
year the
last good year we had i was trying to
say something to people and i did a long
editorial about how we can't
own each other you know no one wants to
try to work together anymore they just
want to own the other side
they don't really want to coexist they
want to vanquish them
and i feel like what you are doing is
trying to say
no that never can work which is what i
was saying
even if the democrats win that all the
republicans in the country are not going
to self-deport
right they're still going to be there is
and i suppose this has always been true
there's the perception of injustice on
all sides which is
probably par for the course but but this
is a we're going to live in a country of
you know 300 million plus
we we we're in a relationship with the
other side you you we have to find a way
you know most relationships if they're
toxic and healthy you leave them we
can't leave this
one we we have to find a way to speak to
one another to listen to one another
find common ground and move the ball
down the field and you know we've just
kind of retreated to our own sides and
it's become such a
toxic culture and i think that breeds uh
apathy and just spirited uh disinterest
and and i think when that happens
politics stops working
the way it could i think you're that is
the exact right analogy it's a
relationship
that you can't leave you know you we
have to find the tools necessary we
can't leave this and that's
pretending out there we can't just
scream louder than you we have to find a
way to speak to each other
and people in a relationship know the
three most important words aren't i love
you they're
let it go oh i was going to say i hear
you
i think the most important thing in my
opinion humble opinion i mean i'm single
so i guess i'm not doing something right
but
but i would argue that i think just
saying or
you again you know it's just to say i
hear what you're saying that doesn't
mean i agree with you
that doesn't mean i endorse what you're
saying it just lets you know that i'm
listening
and i think right away we start to put
our our weaponry down when we realize
that we're in a discussion where someone
else is recognizing
who we are and then you know it's it's
it's not a pleasant process trying to
find common ground and no one's going to
get the whole loaf but but we have to
get better at it
well maybe with women out there hearing
you say how much you like to listen
someone someday that's all this was this
is basically
like my my teacher profile someday
someone will take pity on you
and go out with you i feel for you again
but the other thing i love about it is
there's no likes
i feel like likes have ruined america
they make people
inauthentic and phony and virtue
signaling and
i call it the avatar it's not the real
you it's the you that you put out in
public
and you're you have no message board
there
you have no likes we got to get back to
that right just
information yeah i mean i think you know
being an actor you have an intimate
relationship with message boys and i've
never in my life felt better after
reading one and
and and you know i think politics in
general is
a very you know vitriolic landscape and
i think that's one of the things that
turns people off so so i think we just
wanted to remove
that there are some negative reward
mechanisms when it comes to likes and
comments and things like that and i
think we just wanted to keep it
purely uh scholastic and i i think both
sides i think not only the
the viewers of the site but the
contributors of the site also appreciate
it
and where did you get your interest in
politics was it from your uncle i know
your
uncle mike capiano right yeah he was
the longtime congressman who was
unseated recently by
ayanna presley right that's the district
you are probably in now where you grew
up right
it's actually not where i grew up but
you know next close okay so
is that is that why you became so
interested in politics because of uncle
mike
ma you know maybe my family has always
been
very altruistic very passionate um
unafraid to share their point of view
and uh
uh you know i don't know it's it's to be
honest it's not that i'm interested in
politics you know it's it's more about
trying to
uh help and and politics to me seems
like this
weird broken machine that we've all kind
of given up on but
the truth is if we give it a spit shine
this thing might actually work and and i
and i that that that starts with
participation and engagement and uh
again it's become such a
toxic landscape it it
breeds this exhaustion this people just
can't
they they can't be bothered you know
these are uh you know intelligent people
that i'm speaking about
people who aren't just uh they
understand it's their civic duty but it
still
feels so daunting life as it is is is
overwhelming enough so to
to dive into a pool where everyone is
just so horrible to one another
there's no interest and so i think
there's a way to kind of you know
bring that back to uh you know you don't
see yourself running
ever that's not something in your future
because
we are entering a an era i think i mean
it started with reagan
or even a little before reagan but now
we've moved to trump and
where really people look to show
business
for for for that's who that who has have
credibility they have name recognition
look it's a dumbed-down society so i
think in the future you could see
you know clooney ben affleck a lot of
these people
and uh that's is that for you um
i would never um you know i just don't
know enough that's another thing i think
we're all kind of scared to say i don't
know
i don't know um and and i don't know
enough
so i i wouldn't disservice or disrespect
uh the position by by
thinking that i could handle it i've
thought about
you know somehow helping in that
capacity but it would
it would require a lot of homework well
listen
uh i'm not pushing you to run or not to
run but i just want to disabuse you of
this one thing
i've spent a very long time on
television talking an awful lot of
politicians
and i know you pretty well by now you
know a lot more than a lot of them do
they're [ __ ] idiots a lot of them all
you need to run
is a [ __ ] clip-on tie and a suit
there's no qualifications
and that's proven every day by the guy
at the top of the world right now
he knows absolutely nothing you know
what always don't run if you don't want
to but don't do it because you think you
know less than they do
because they don't they don't have to
know anything and many of them don't
well i i think my heart's in the right
place but uh
there's a real there's a real you know
tapestry of cause and effect you know
you might think you're fixing one thing
and the downstream impact
is something you could have never been
aware of and so i i just think before i
dove into that recklessly i think you
can get away with that in in my industry
you can say i'm gonna i'm gonna
try and direct why not you know i think
i think when it comes to politics you
gotta have a little bit more
uh reverence okay well i'm actually to
see your next projects i always enjoy
you in the movies
i hope the epidemic uh ends to the
pandemic and soon and your uh loneliness
epidemic
uh will follow soon after that i i i
thanks to this show
this is it this was it put out the
steelers thoughts and prayers
evans all right we'll see you soon
thanks for joining